Christmas that magical time of year
crackling log fires freshly fallen snow
twinkling lights and murderous monster
cats Krampus isn't the only Christmas
monster
so is this well a much larger version of
this known as the Ewell cat but don't be
fooled
while it may be fluffy unlike this kitty
the Ewell cat is no cuddly creature
called the Yola Girton from the
Icelandic word for you'll and petition
this creepy kitty prowls the streets
looking for its prey anyone who has not
received new clothes by Christmas but
Iceland has no wild large predatory cat
species so why does this creature take
on a feline appearance and why do these
monstrous fashion critics only attack
people with old clothes to find out we
have to take a look at Icelandic
mythology the importance of oral
storytelling and wool production also
murder flutes
I'm dr. Emily szarka and this is monstre
with glowing eyes and sharp whiskers the
Ewell cat towers over houses as it
prowls the snowy streets hunting people
rather than mice the Ewell cat's
favorite prey is children the giant
feline lurks along snowy streets and
country's eyes
checking in windows to see which
children received new clothes for
Christmas if the Ewell cat spots anyone
with frayed or torn clothing he eats
them
perhaps the most famous account of the
Ewell cat and the one most modern
Icelanders are familiar with comes from
a poem Bjork even did a cover of it from
the book christmas is coming first
published in 1932 but translated to
English for the first time in 2015 the
author writes he opened his glaring eyes
wide the two of them glowing bright it
took a really brave man to look straight
into them his whiskers sharp his
bristles his back arched up high and the
claws of his hairy paws were a terrible
sight he gave a wave of his strong tail
he jumped any clawed and he hissed
sometimes up in the valley sometimes
down by the shore he roamed at large
hungry and evil in the freezing you'll
snow in every home people shuddered at
his name if one heard a pitiful meow
something evil would happen soon
everybody knew he hunted men but didn't
care for mice doesn't that give you the
warm fuzzies before we dive through the
possible reasons why this monster exists
we must first position him as part of a
larger tradition where does this yield
cat come from legend and literary
history tells us that he is actually the
pet of a family of trolls including the
Yule Lads
Iceland does not actually have a Santa
Claus the Yule Lads or Christmas lads
serve as the gift givers children
receive presents from every year while
the number of lads ranges from 9 to 22
the most common number is 13 since
around the 17th century these trolls
came down from their mountain homes one
by one over a period of 13 days before
Christmas to leave small presents
and cause a little mischief along the
way the brothers have very odd names
like stubby window peeper and spoon
licker in the 20th century the Yule Lads
adopted red clothing and white beards
inspired by the Santa Claus from other
cultures but these seemingly harmless
trolls were not always so friendly
originally it was said that they came
down from the mountains not to spread
Christmas cheer but to terrify children
into obedience they carried off the ones
who misbehaved or cried too much this
was a successful enough deterrent that
it actually caused a bit of panic enough
so that in 1746 a regulation was issued
from the government saying the foolish
custom which has been practiced here and
there about the country of scaring
children with Yuletide lads or ghosts
shall be abolished I should also mention
that the Yule Lads have quite the famous
mother kryla who has been around since
at least the early 13th century early
versions describe the troll with three
hundred heads 15 tails goat horns long
ears and a beard out in the Ewell cat is
just one big happy wicked family I had
the privilege of speaking to the
foremost authority in Iceland on Yule
tradition Arne bjornsen who told me
pinpointing the exact origins of the
Yule cat is a particularly slippery
problem according to him scholars don't
know if this creature was widely known
in the country before the first edition
of Iceland's folk tales were published
in the nineteenth century but while the
Yule cat may have an indeterminate
history there are some compelling
theories as to why the creature exists I
think par the reason lies in the fact
that cats have always been more common
than dogs in Iceland both as pets and
wild animals dogs were even banned from
the country in 1924 and dog owners today
must obtain a special permit to keep a
canine companion cats also served an
important function in Icelandic
mythology the goddess of love and
sorcery Freya travelled across the sky
in a wagon pulled by two giant flying
cats specifically cats resembling the
Norwegian Forest Cat
I'm not much of a cat person but even I
and smitten by these large extra fluffy
kitties the Norwegian Forest cats
prevalence and mythology and as house
pets may account for the you'll catch
shaggy appearance
dr. bjornsen along with other scholars
proposed the creation of the Ewell cat
may also have been influenced by the
Norwegian Yule goat like the Ewell cat
this mythical creature is also
associated with a gift-giving entity
this time st. Nicholas st. Nick was said
to ride on a goat or parade a large one
around on a chain while delivering
presents to symbolize his power over the
devil then there's the possibility that
another icelandic feline legend played a
role the wasteland cat or ghoul cat
larger and more ferocious than regular
cats these monsters bury themselves in
the ground preferably in a cemetery at
an early age it can grow to the size of
a large dog before springing from the
ground to roam the rocky terrain
attacking sheep birds and humans as the
story goes the wasteland cats powerful
gaze can kill a human outright goat
Saint Nick a goddess the devil and yet
another cat with a taste for human flesh
that's a lot to consider but the Yule
cat's connection to clothing however
reveals an interesting social aspect to
Icelandic culture most scholars myself
included agree that the threat of the
Yule cat represents a rather practical
problem the need for warm clothes in a
successful wool production Iceland began
exporting well in the Middle Ages and it
became vital to the Icelandic economy
and survival during this time wool
related chores were the responsibility
of the entire household after the food
preparations for winter were completed
in autumn the largest tasks at hand were
spinning and weaving casual workers and
boarders in a homestead were often paid
in wool Icelandic sheep's wool has two
kinds of hair a coarse more water
resistant top layer and the inner
insulating layer these would be
separated by hand and used for different
textiles
men women and children would tease cards
spin and knit the wool in order to
produce yarn to sell they would also
knit garments for winter in the past
Christmas gifts among most people were
sparse and usually consisted of some
small piece of clothing but that was
only possible if everyone had
participated in an annual production of
wool and done their fair share of the
work because the Ewell cat only attacks
people who do not receive new clothes
this monster likely emerged as a
response to the importance of wool
production scaring children and even
adults into finishing their textile work
in time for Christmas and the coldest
part of the year the tradition of the
Yule cap promoted a strong work ethic
and appropriate preparation for winter
but it also helped encourage familial
and social bonding gathering the
household together around the fire on
winter nights to work on wool production
served an educational function Iceland
had almost total Universal literacy in
the 19th century including in the lower
classes even without a significant
educational infrastructure children
learned to read and write while these
chores took place after children learned
the alphabet they were instructed to
read out loud to entertain the older
participants and improve their own
literacy frequently these stories
included elves trolls and other
supernatural beings
what was once a ferocious morning
against laziness is now just a quirky
part of Iceland's Yule traditions in
2018 the city of Reykjavik installed a 5
meter high six meter long led sculpture
of the Yule cap it's glowing red eyes
serving as a playful reminder of the
importance of hard work and as a display
of the power of storytelling the great
cost of the statue caused controversy
but nonetheless it continues to attract
crowds every year around Christmas
Bjork's famous musical rendition of the
1932 'you'll cap poem can be heard on
radio stations across iceland the famous
feline inspires books holiday greeting
cards and even chocolate the Ewell cat
legend shows us how Icelandic culture
emphasized the importance of hard work
it served as a warning to young children
that being lazy would have serious
consequences
not the least of which included being
clawed and eaten alive by a massive cat
so may your days be merry and bright and
may all your Christmases be free of
giant flesh-eating murder flutes you are
danger well it may be [ __ ]